hey everybody
notice it's just me i don't know why tom
didn't get his butt in here on time but
i'm just go ahead and starting it
because whatever
uh yeah and i just right before i
started recording i
lost my pen i don't know where the
[ __ ] poltergeist must have taken it
because i have no [ __ ] idea where it
just i just
had it i just had the [ __ ] things not
this one i had a different one
all right i already
i'm being robbed of ice in this house
robbed of ice yeah i don't know how it
happens every now and then that damn bar
inside the ice maker did you
did you take my pen got it right here
well not that pen
it was a different pattern that was the
only pain i had okay got that pin right
over here
your poltergeist took my pen did it
because i just got this pin right over
there
okay yeah i had to get i need to dig
this one out of my purse and it doesn't
really work i have no idea where my
other pen went
i don't know i just had it like 10
minutes ago it's a [ __ ] mystery i
don't know what's going on
look at it she's starting the show
without me well you heard it you weren't
in here
i was coming it's three o'clock you can
make him wait for a second to go hey
tom go to the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like get
your ass in here
you need to plan ahead that's what you
need i did plan ahead no you didn't play
i
made like an iced tea that's good and
then i'm gonna go in there and make a
whole gallon of lemonade when the show's
over
alex ramirez oh okay tom's back i
thought maybe the poltergeist
transported him yeah it took me to the
same place where
it took my pen i really must have fought
it
all i have is that sharpie right there
and i got it underneath yeah it's not
that one it's like this it's like a
ballpoint but it's black
this one like i said this one i dug out
of my purse just because
uh i don't see it i don't know i
probably have more in my drawer
somewhere no
it's it's all right i just i'll just
need it again later because i can't do
anything without a bed
all right uh all right got 13 people on
here yeah why is my phone ringing
uh they're calling you you guys calling
you guys calling jenny nobody's calling
me
i don't know who the hell it's not the
same number but it's uh it probably is
it's probably like bill collectors
it's like it's an indian call center
well actually it's coming from uh
the 386 exchange which is felucia county
somewhere where i used to live
yeah daytime i don't know like i said
it's probably
you got a traffic ticket no no
i don't think i've ever got a traffic
ticket now that i think about it i've
got warnings a couple of times yeah
for speeding and [ __ ] but i don't think
i ever got a ticket i need to pay that
i don't want [ __ ] be sitting up here one
day and [ __ ] boba fett jumps through
the [ __ ] room
looking for you yeah i'm i'm an
international criminal
i'm like what the [ __ ] well yeah i'm
just gonna say around i'm an
international diamond smuggler right um
you know what i mean
i'm wanted in 30 countries i think it's
international terrorists and [ __ ] i
resist and get [ __ ] mowed down
because you didn't put it down
yeah i'm sure they're really gonna come
after me for not paying a parking ticket
dude i didn't even like i had i had a
mortgage that was underwater many years
ago
and i just kind of the house because
well no they stopped [ __ ] with me
after a while
and they stopped [ __ ] with me after a
while everybody and everybody [ __ ]
got a
got a that's what i mean it was kind of
like happened
to everybody around the same time so
they they [ __ ] me with me for a while
and
all day but after 2008 financial [ __ ]
collapse or wasn't it two thousand yeah
yeah or something like that yeah economy
collection because the house i bought
for
and this was like years and years ago
but i bought a house for 85 000
and then when i was gonna sell it they
were like well maybe you could get
thirty five thousand and i was like dude
i still owe like seventy thousand on it
yeah so i was like okay [ __ ] it i'm
leaving yeah but yeah so uh they
stopped [ __ ] with me as that was like
a long time ago yeah so uh they probably
don't even care anymore i just don't
know
i i kind of feel like those calls are
probably they're all coming from that
area so it's probably just i don't know
it's
sales or some [ __ ] like that because i
don't ever answer my phone
business is going through mexican
customs right now oh really that's what
he says
[Laughter]
that's that's cool yeah and he works
over there well okay i got you
it crosses the border every day that
must be
yeah a pain in the ass yep um all right
so
i wanted to do another little matinee
because there was another uh
movie that shutter added that was a
fairly new movie i think it just
premiered at
some film festival uh in scandinavia
in november and then it just dropped on
shutter like
maybe a week or two ago yes this is a
norwegian movie called
lake of death yeah now
this movie i didn't know until i started
going and doing
uh research on it but apparently this is
actually based on
a novel from 1942 called lake of the
damned
and that was actually made into a movie
already in the 1950s
and that movie like i think it was 1958
and that movie was apparently like a big
like um
norwegian horror classic or whatever so
this is essentially a remake or a like
another version of the book
yeah that sounds yeah that it's clicking
now
the movie didn't really this is a
well-made movie it looks really good
it's got a good cast in it it's it's all
in foreign language
but it didn't really it didn't really
catch me early so i didn't i didn't
i wasn't really yeah this was like all i
wanted what i want to say was
is this making sense what you're saying
because this movie reminded me a lot of
that remake of the the turning
yeah this wasn't better than that
because a lot better but that movie i
could tell you angry i could tell that
it was
based on some kind of a book or based on
something else and it was
it's real serious the tone is serious uh
for me you know what i mean i kind of
like the brazilian one better i like
this
well because that was so wacky [ __ ]
wacky [ __ ] i like that better but
this for me it's more fun this is
actually a very serious horror movie
yeah and it was like it's one of those
ones where i mean
like i said i liked this movie a lot
better than the turning but i will say
that it's not going to be anything
that's going to be
like a super standout or anything it's
just like a solid
um you know creepy maybe supernatural
maybe something else is going on type of
movie
it's almost it's weird because it's kind
of like a throwback
i mean which makes sense that the novel
was written in the 40s
but it's very much like a cabin in the
woods type of
horror movie which obviously has been
done a lot since then so i'm sure it was
probably like a lot fresher like back in
the 40s when that hadn't been done much
one thing that the filmmaker did do is
you could tell
that uh whoever made the uh the person
that made this movie
uh needy bull robs robsom i think is
their name
um they are a big horror fan because
there are
a lot of references to other horror
movies in this uh specifically
there are two references that i noticed
to nightmare on elm street like one of
them they even recreated like the
bathtubs
very famous bathtub scene where nancy's
in there and the claw comes up uh they
did something very similar to that
um and they also made a reference to
freddy krueger they made a couple
references to evil dead
um you know specifically with this cabin
and with it like the basement like
you know in the way the door came up and
stuff um and
there was just even even like i don't
even know if this was a direct reference
even though it was the first thing that
i thought of
there might have been even a direct
reference to the raft
that stephen king story that was yeah
like made into a movie later it's funny
because
the opening the opening part of the
movies kind of reminded me of that yeah
and there was one scene like late in the
movie where black [ __ ] started coming up
through like the thing and it reminded
me very much of that
like from creep show too yeah i really
didn't even catch that they had
uh that they had [ __ ] made references
to nightmare on elm street and evil dead
at that point i really what kind of was
zoning out at it it's a little slow
it is it's not super long it's only like
an hour and a half
um it's a well done movie though i'll
tell you it had really good underwater
shots
i really i think that was like the best
the cinematography is really nice like
wherever they shot this like
because obviously it's like this you
know kind of creepy old cabin on this
really big beautiful
lake in uh norway i'm assuming um
and yeah the underwater shots at the end
were gorgeous they were like these
really dream like uh kind of shots
and the characters like i didn't even
realize this either until i researched
it a little bit
but apparently even though the movie is
norwegian
um the characters in it are actually
speaking three different languages
they're actually speaking norwegian
danish and swedish i believe but i i
mean obviously i didn't know that
because you know it was all just
subtitled they're
in english they all sound sad but
apparently well yeah it like all sounded
similar enough that i wouldn't have
noticed that but i guess like a native
speaker would notice
um in a couple times like one character
did say to another and hey what does
that word mean like when one had like
something written on his forehead and he
has oh it's the norwegian word for
whatever so you know what i mean
they did kind of make a mention that one
of them was danish so but i didn't
really
put that together but the characters in
in this are um
pretty likable basically what the setup
is it's a very simple setup um
it's just there's kind of like a small
prologue there's this uh girl named
lillian
and she had a twin brother named bjorn
and he had
apparently uh you know there's kind of a
little thing with them they're you know
they have like the weird twin synergy
thing going on
and um he disappears uh
a year previously they don't go a huge
amount into the disappearance if they
say he disappears and they presume that
he's dead
um i don't even remember if they said
they presumed he drowned in the lake
they just said he went off in the woods
and he never came back and they never
found his body
so a year later um she comes back with a
bunch of her friends
and they're going to because she's going
to sell the cabin
and um her friends are like encouraged
her to go out there like for
some closure or whatever because they
think that she needs that
but when she gets out there she starts
um
experiencing weird [ __ ] and it seems
like a lot of her other friends are
experiencing weird [ __ ] too
um in the sense that you know like weird
[ __ ] will happen
like she starts sleepwalking she starts
having these creepy nightmares
shit'll happen like they'll all get up
and the table's been set for breakfast
but nobody did it like nobody's like did
you
make breakfast no i didn't make
breakfast and like there's a chair out
there and like there's a plate there
like somebody's eating there and they
don't know who it is
so it seems like someone's creeping
around
uh [ __ ] with them but they're not
sure if it's a living person because
then they start like getting suspicious
of each other
like thinking one of them is doing the
prank because there's one guy
who's along with him who's like you know
uh the fifth wheel type of dude who's
actually
was probably my favorite character
because he was kind of funny but he had
like a paranormal podcast
so he was like the first one to get the
blame
like every time like something creepy
happened because everybody thought he
was just doing it like to make the show
more exciting or whatever
so funny how like podcasters and
youtubers are now like main characters
in movies now
well i thought of that [ __ ] yeah it's
funny because i know i've seen so many
movies and normally it's like i don't
know i might get into this a little bit
because
i feel like it's really really hard
because i've seen a lot of movies where
the main plot of the story revolved
around
a youtube channel or so you know a movie
like
cam or a movie like or something like
that where
i think we reviewed one too well there's
so many paranormal [ __ ] youtubers and
[ __ ] youtube shows that a paranormal
movie is going to be about
that scene yeah remember that [ __ ] yeah
i mean uh the the brazilian wasn't the
only one like that
there well there have been a lot yeah
and we saw we i don't think we reviewed
it but there is another one on shutter
that i think
was was it korean what was it was it
called 0.0 megahertz or something like
this
and that i think it was korean like we
watched it it was pretty good but it was
like
youtube paranormal yeah we just never
got around to reviewing it yeah um but
it was the same
thing though yeah it was just kind of a
middle of the road yes or i don't even
really remember that much about it
kind of like a derivative korean ripoff
of everything else all just kind of
combined into one
yeah like the ring over and over again
everything kind of like in the main i
really i tend not to like movies that
are based around
like i said a technology of the moment
yeah um
on the other hand it's kind of hard to
make a movie
yeah with that without talking about
well
if you ask me youtube is the modern
version of television i'm sure when
tv first came out movies didn't want to
reference what was going on in tv
tv wasn't considered to be like a real
medium when it first came out
yeah did you know that yeah i know yeah
they're like if you're on tv you weren't
[ __ ]
yeah which is funny because that kind of
switched around yeah i mean
because nowadays it seems like well i i
feel like
the distinction has vanished yeah um you
know what i mean it's no
it's either you're going to streaming or
a cable show where it's really no
distinction anymore
yeah because people just they don't a
lot of people don't watch things
even on the original you know platform
for which it was made you're just going
to stream it later when it comes out of
netflix or whatever
even if it came out originally as a
cable show right so
it doesn't really matter the cable's
[ __ ] dead man but
it's that's the thing it's like it's
really seems really hard to do
um because you see movies like friend or
friend request
or you know movies like that where it's
based around
or the one we saw that was called uh amy
like ami
which i don't even remember if we
reviewed that one or not it wasn't
really that great
um where it was like a you know like a
siri type app that was like evil it like
made you do evil [ __ ]
and it's i understand that you know in
the modern era it's everyone's life
is so wrapped up in technology that it's
kind of hard to avoid
but in some ways i feel like it kind of
cripples you as well because
one it dates the movie um
you know people are going to watch that
20 years from now
and be like look at that lame ass
[ __ ] because whatever the [ __ ] they
have in 20 years is gonna like
be way better than what the [ __ ] we have
it dates your movie and also i just
i don't know if there's something about
it that sort of bothers me i've seen
ones that i liked
you know what i mean yeah it's kind of
it but i don't know though i mean i
i'm watching like there's there's a
youtube show called wang
he's he's like a chinese american guy
long hair looks like a metal head and he
does all these cool little programs on
[ __ ] that happened on the internet
back in the 90s in the 2000s
and it's funny because he would show
sites from the 80s and the 90s and and i
forgot the way the old internet was
yeah you could go to the wayback machine
yeah that stuff is ugly as hell
yeah and but there's kind of like a
sense of nostalgia when he starts
telling the stories
of like internet internet stories and
internet memes from the 90s
yeah from the late 90s in the early
2000s you know what i mean
i remember some of that some of the
weird [ __ ] that was going on at that
time yeah
on message boards and and and because
that seemed like where most of the
activity yeah
and memes of the time and songs and like
their people were lifting little bits of
[ __ ]
uh of music out of video games and
putting those on
on on the web as background music for
some [ __ ] picture that they made you
know just funny [ __ ] you know
everything was so cobbled together yeah
it's all cobbled together because
everybody had dial up
yeah yeah everything was super slow it
had a certain
you were saying that it would it might
age funny date
it might do the reverse it might be very
nostalgic
that's what i think will happen it's
just yeah it might just be very
nostalgic it'll be like oh i remember
back in 2020 when they had that
i was re well when i was a kid back in
2020
it's interesting because i was just uh i
was
watching a video essay the other day
about how
uh a lot of comedy ages badly and this
is something that we've talked
about comedy is like [ __ ] and i think
that horror might have a similar problem
because what so what he was talking
about a little bit you know with
comedies because he's talking about you
know watch
like ace ventura or something like that
nowadays and it seems really
cringe-worthy and he was kind of trying
to explain why that was
and i think a lot of the things like
still apply
with horror in the sense that one
you know even if you see a trope like
when for example the blair witch project
came out
that was a very new like the found
footage thing hadn't been done a million
times you know it had only been done a
couple times before like cannibal
holocaust and maybe a couple it's like
the last broadcast or whatever
um so you know you got that so it was
like a big thing
but now that it's been done so many
times that now it's its own
sub genre and people are kind of like
sick of it you know what i mean so
you can see just through repetition that
it's going to be kind of
you know hard to do but also i don't
know it's just
it just seems to me and i feel like i'm
one of those people that's like
if you have a good if you're a good
enough writer and if it's a movie if you
have a good enough characters then you
know people you care about
and it's a decent concept i mean you can
make a good movie
out of anything pretty much anything i'm
not going to say anything anything
because i'm sure somebody will come up
with something that you could
that's impossible to make a good movie
about i'm sure there's something
but i mean you can make a good movie out
of
almost anything you know i would be
hard-pressed to think of something that
you couldn't make a good move but you
have to be clever about it
and so i'm not gonna say that there's
not a good movie to be made
about you know a killer app for example
or someone who's a podcaster or
something like that
but it's just that so many of them are
crap
that you get you know remember that
remember that [ __ ] terrible movie
johnny demonic
johnny demonic yeah where he's like a
human [ __ ] thumb drive
that's right that didn't age well did it
no it didn't
really well for some reason he could
store
computer data in his head and he would
transport it like a smuggler
pre pre-internet like people in the
cloud
people that are like teenagers are in
their 20s now are watching that going
what the [ __ ]
what do you need that for yeah what is
that even [ __ ] computer programs in
your head and you take it to somewhere
and sell to somebody
in a file you know you know and it's
only like a megabyte
you know oh
it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] movie there it's a
yeah i haven't seen it forever i don't
even remember if i've seen the whole
thing
it didn't make sense to me back then
when i saw it it's true
i just feel like it's anything you're
gonna do that's like
of the moment and this was another thing
that this guy was pointing out i can't
i think it was renegade cut the channel
on youtube where he was talking about
like why comedy ages so badly
and he was kind of talking in particular
too about and we've talked about this
before too
is those terrible um like parody movies
like scary movie and
uh that kind of [ __ ] that parodied
horror movies
and they're like the problem with a lot
of those is a lot of the parodies or a
lot of the jokes they're making about is
are so of the moment and some of the
stuff that they make fun of are just
were just like commercials and stuff
like that and that
you know five years from now no one's
gonna remember that [ __ ] so it's like
you're not gonna remember what the
reference to the joke was
i can go back even further than that to
those mel brooks movies most of those
didn't age too well
some of them did though i mean young
frankenstein is still hilarious to me
history of the world is not funny
blazing saddles is still funny yeah
that's right both probably so funny
[ __ ] what uh i haven't seen history
i probably haven't seen that it wasn't
[ __ ] funny anymore it was funny when
i was a kid i haven't seen it since i
was a teenager it's kind of like eddie
murphy raw
the stand-up show that was [ __ ]
hilarious back in those days i look at
it now and i'm like
[ __ ] man that's just like a regular dude
talking that's not funny
yeah well back in those days as i said
you know things are like
shocking at the time and anything it
doesn't even have to do with like being
shocking
it just has to do with what people have
gotten used to yeah
you know you know as i said blair witch
project made of all the money in the
world
because no one had seen anything like
that not just the movie itself but the
whole marketing campaign about it where
they were making it like it was a real
thing and like the actors had to go into
hiding and [ __ ]
yes cannibal holocaust did it like many
many years before that
but that one wasn't as well known at
least in the united states
so to most people this was like the
first time they had done this the first
time they were
experiencing something that was like an
alternate reality game before that even
had a
and that was early internet era yeah and
that helped
with that yeah when was that
it was 99 very early internet beginning
of [ __ ] order and [ __ ] [ __ ] off
the [ __ ] internet
you know you you talking on live tv yeah
and
web tv and uh dude yeah that's [ __ ]
funny time
and then listening to art bell uh live
stream over the radio
live streaming live you know
they would live stream his show his
radio show
online yeah and that was like [ __ ] a
big deal
because i couldn't pick it up on fm
radio right where i was well yeah
because you weren't
yeah i wasn't close enough you know what
i mean to
but you could go online and they were
live streaming the radio transmission i
thought that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] high
speed man
like whoa it's the future yeah it's like
the future already
it's like the jets yeah just like
[ __ ] just just like
just like [ __ ] total recall yeah
yeah remember back in the old days when
you couldn't listen to a radio station
that was like the next town over yeah
he's too far away
you couldn't get it to come in because
like every now and then because like you
know i grew up in daytona
all we had was like [ __ ] country
stations and like classic rock and [ __ ]
so it's like i would always try to get
like the college station from
gainesville
yeah um every now and then if the
weather was right
you could get it and it was kind of
radio yeah yeah you're like
trying to like point the radio at the
window and [ __ ]
trying to get
on the other end try to make a bigger
antenna
yeah but dark times back i have [ __ ]
web tv
and i was [ __ ] tripping out i was
like man i'm in the future this
i i thought i thought i was in the
running man remember when [ __ ]
when arnold [ __ ] gets a plane ticket
to hawaii yeah over the television
i thought that [ __ ] was [ __ ] and now
people are watching it going
now people are going what the [ __ ] is
that they're doing it on their phone
yeah you can just do it when you're
[ __ ]
just okay he paid for it he paid for a
plane ticket
on the television using his credit card
he swiped his card
swiped his card little did they know you
don't even have to do that anymore
[Laughter]
you could just go dink you could just
touch it with the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but yeah it's like it's funny because
well it's weird how we went off on that
tangent because
i mean in this movie it doesn't really
the fact that this guy has a paranormal
podcast
it it doesn't factor into the plot
um it kind of only serves as one so he
gets blamed when weird [ __ ] starts
happening at the cabin
and two so that they can give some
backstory about like a creepy legend
uh about the lake like about this person
that like uh killed his wife and kid and
then like jumped into the lake and
um you know and and then there's this
whole urban legend about if you like
fall into the lake like you live forever
or something like that it's like a lake
not a lake monster but like a lake ghost
type of uh
legend so the fact that that he has a
paranormal podcast means he can
interview somebody about the legend of
the lake so you so he can tell the
audience so that's kind of like what it
is
they're talking about reading lovecraft
in the comment section
yeah reading lovecraft is kind of a
chore because
lovecraft his stories are not about what
happened or
action they're not really action stories
they're more about
mood yeah mood and he's usually telling
you about something that already
happened
true it's weird so it's kind of it's
kind of like re it's kind of like
reading old
1800s gothic stuff from the 1800s is
what it's like reading
i've read some on my on witching hour
like some lovecraft stories not a lot
because i feel like they've
you know a lot of them have been read
and a lot of people have heard them
so i try not to unless it's you know
it's one that doesn't get
get read very much but um not a modern
style his stories tend to be very
short i've noticed um so it's like if i
you know need a story that only takes me
10 minutes to read to slap on the end of
the witching hour show and just put a
lovecraft one on there like fit in with
theme
but something i've noticed and that it's
another thing too with horror stories
and i haven't read i hate to say but i
haven't read like a lot of
real recent horror fiction just because
i haven't had time
i like a lot of classic old ghost
stories
but i will say that i can see why people
might not
be into them because just like anything
else
i feel like it was not a new medium
necessarily but maybe there were some
you know literary devices and things
like that that were
you know uh kind of new back then
but they've been done so many times
subsequently because you know they
these were very influential that by the
time you go back and read the original
one it sounds
it doesn't sound original because you've
read
all the [ __ ] that came later you know
what i mean and i think that happens
with movies a lot too
um just in the sense that you see a
horror movie nowadays
and you know or you go back and watch an
old one and i and somebody was saying
this
uh too in some of the comments of like
that video essay i was like they were
like
the thing about it is that you know they
were younger and they said i had heard
so much about the exorcist and i had
never seen it because they were younger
and it came out in the 70s
so when they finally went back to see it
it didn't have the same impact because
it's been so
memeed and so talked about and people
have seen clips of it it's been parodied
and everything like that that
it's never going to have the same impact
as you just coming at it
with you know no preconceptions yeah
especially in the time in which it came
out
right and like which is kind of a shame
young guys
young guys can can today appreciate
things like
terminator or predator the very first
predator when it came
out but you will never know what it was
like
to be about 16 or 17 sitting in the
audience
seeing predator for the first time and
that thing takes its [ __ ] mask off
yeah you know i mean i saw it like on
day two
second day of the release nothing had
leaked there was no internet you
couldn't get spoilers over the internet
yeah a lot of [ __ ] wasn't ruined for yet
no and when that thing
when that predator took that [ __ ]
mask off i thought i had seen the top
i thought i thought i had seen the
monster yeah it took that [ __ ] mask
off and that face looks so
real and it still stands up to to today
it still looks really good it looks real
even compared to the other
the newer ones it looks better than the
newer ones that that original [ __ ]
well yeah that's an actual it looks
[ __ ] good
and i just felt like i had seen a
[ __ ] extraterrestrial and the [ __ ]
whole side
the whole audience just went [ __ ]
silent
because they had never seen anything
that
looked that good you know what i mean up
until that point the only thing that was
close to that was like alien
yeah the xenomorph the xenomorphs real
close
but man that thing took its [ __ ] mask
off and i was just like what the
[ __ ] and i immediately realized i was
seeing a masterpiece
well yeah as soon as i saw that face i
was just like this movie is a [ __ ]
masterpiece
and it just stood the test in a way
that's i mean i don't
i don't mind and there's i mean there's
nothing you can do about it now so it's
no
sense in like whinging about it but you
know the ubiquity
of pop culture nowadays everybody i mean
you can't avoid it
and even like old pop culture from when
we were kids like everybody knows about
it
so even if you've never seen the movie
you can't watch it
without any preconceptions without
because you've heard about it you've
heard about it
means of it you've seen clips of it and
it has its place in society already
when that thing was new it was an
unknown quantity
yeah our reactions to it made it
legendary yeah because that thing was
[ __ ] when it was brand new
there was nothing like that and it was
just a cut above the rest and
it was and i think that that costume was
made by a kid wasn't it
a guy who was pretty well he was yet
very young yeah young at the time but he
was just [ __ ] fantastic work yeah
because i think the original was a
the original costume they had for it was
like really stupid looking
yeah then they took it out predator
the predator that we know was the second
one the first one didn't look good
yeah because they did it and they're
like we can't put that in there
category one was saved during reshoots
yeah
but then there was another thing is that
you could watch terminator 1 today and
it does not have the same impact as it
did
when it came out for us when we were
young yeah because terminator 1
nobody knew who david cameron was or
james cameron yeah this is the james
chain camera
we didn't really know who that was and
that movie just came out of left field
it was just another arnold movie and we
were just like
wow what the [ __ ] and this idea that
there was a robot underneath there and
then you got to eventually see it see i
thought
i thought i thought as i was watching
that movie
i thought it was a kind of i liked it
but i was like it's a ripoff it's a way
of getting around
having to make a monster yeah like no
you saw the monster
the skin burns off of it and then you
see the [ __ ] robot
and it was just in in the context of the
time
it was [ __ ] awesome and it was a
horror movie it wasn't a sci-fi movie it
was a horror movie for us
yeah it was like jaws this [ __ ] kept
coming well it definitely is i mean it
has sci-fi elements obviously
but it's structured much more like a
heart and everybody seems to like t2 now
i was there man when that [ __ ] was new
i didn't really like t2 as much i loved
it when it came out but when i watched
it again years later i didn't like it as
well i just thought it was okay
mostly because that kid was annoying
yeah i didn't realize kid either and and
i
he didn't seem annoying in the 90s
because all the other kids and movies
were like that
but when i see it now like you know 10
20 years on
for me what made the terminator so good
was that arnold is a bad guy
and you see he wasn't going to do any
more villain stuff so they had to get
bring a new villain
which is the liquid metal guy and it
just to me it just didn't do the same
it wasn't the same well it was okay we
mentioned before that arnold actually
the roles that i like him in are when he
plays a villain yeah and he didn't like
to play a villain he likes to play a
hero
and i feel like when he has to play a
hero they have to inject humor into it
just because oh look he has a funny
accent or look he's a big huge muscle
guy and he has to do this you know
feminine thing like watch a bunch of
kindergartners or some [ __ ] like that
you know what i mean
so it's like they always have to like
make it funny which
undercuts any suspense or anything like
that which is kind of a shame he
really should play more he should have
played more bad guys he was afraid he'd
go out of style if he did that though
because he might have but he was
probably right about that because the
villains all get defeated
and then they just see you being
defeated over and over again we talked
about that in once upon a time yeah
exactly he knew exactly we're talking
about is true
i just i just feel like he does play
better villains yeah because when he
plays a good guy they always have to
make him
he's more convincing as a villain he is
that's what i'm saying because he's like
he's a big
stoic yeah dude and when they put him in
like a serious role or a good guy role
they have to work around that somehow
and they usually do that by making it
like comedic
and i don't you know i've liked a lot of
his you know where he plays a good guy
too
but and i feel like he's gotten you know
the roles that he's done
more recently like maggie and stuff like
that where he's just playing a normal
person without having to be like a smart
ass or
you know or dorky or anything like that
they're talking about what their dad
saw on the original and that they i saw
star wars one
in 1977 on day two
at uh uh man's chinese theater
in in [ __ ] um la
so that's where that's where it was
opened and i saw the original cut
and that was the cut that was it later
on
i was when i saw it again like for the
fourth and fifth time [ __ ] was missing
but the it had a scene where he where
biggs was trying to tell luke to join
the rebellion
that was in the first couple times i saw
it
and then there was also a scene where
[ __ ] c-3po was [ __ ] uh
um driving the the um um
the landspeeder yeah yeah that that was
in the original cuts that i saw but then
they
they trimmed it down it trimmed this
thing out sometimes they cut up movies
while they're in theaters yep
they did the same i was in the theater i
was just listening to uh
somebody talk uh grumpy andrew yeah
andrew's house before he was talking
about
uh the terrible exorcist too and um
he was talking about how that was
edited twice while it was in the
theaters well just because it was like
doing so because it's a terrible another
one i saw them uh edited in the theater
was alien 2
aliens originally when i saw it it had
it had a scene in there where um the
marines had set up some automatic guns
to protect their
robot guns to protect their perimeter
and the aliens were just running into
them damn guns chewing up all the ammo
a lot of them got killed trying to fight
those guns they cut that scene out
but you can find it online yeah but
originally when i saw it that was in
there and when i saw
saw the movie again i was like hey what
happened to the scene where
the robot guns were shooting and the
[ __ ] counters all the ammunition was
going down another where'd that go
yeah where'd that go yeah they took that
out
but um seeing star wars
brand new i was about eight years old
this [ __ ] blew my mind we had never
seen anything like that
with the [ __ ] big triangular ship
flying overhead and the next thing you
know i just saw c3po this [ __ ] robot
with r2d2 running running around in the
ship talking and
everybody's laughing i was dumbfounded
what the [ __ ] am i looking at and that
was like the first
really convincing
space futuristic setting
yeah you know you could totally buy it
and it was just like it was badass man
and then um
you know tijuan new was really good just
all that [ __ ] that you guys remember
seeing it for the first time
i don't think those days are ever coming
back and it was i think a lot of it had
to do with the fact that
we were kind of naive and didn't and and
that type of cinema was new and nobody
really knew what the extent of special
effects could do
no special effects or nothing no you can
just do anything you can do anything you
want
back then you couldn't it was special
effects were real expensive and you
weren't
we didn't know how convincing they could
be and i think that was a huge
factor yeah and so imagery had a lot of
impact on us back then
now imagery doesn't mean anything well
like i said because it's ubiquitous yeah
and because i mean and like i said it's
not younger people's fault
that they were born later and so they
um you know have already had the
experience all these like movies and
[ __ ] like that it's like in their past
you know what i mean so they've
kids are already seen all of it kids are
growing up with [ __ ]
phones and and and mobile devices
that can make imagery far beyond what we
what we
ever could imagine back in the 70s yeah
yeah i mean like uh you have an hd
capabilities on a handheld device that's
just
which is crazy never thought of that
anything like that no i would never have
so i mean i knew
[ __ ] was going to be like futuristic
obviously but i thought it was gonna be
like alien too
yeah you know aliens yeah if you look at
the [ __ ] that they have it's not very
futuristic
everything they look very strange
i mean a lot of that stuff that does
look like military and industrial
equipment you know anything military is
bulky and [ __ ] strong and
dumb dumbed down but it has to be
because you know it has to operate
between
50 to minus 50 degrees below zero up to
about 230 degrees that's about what they
want it to survive
you know what i mean so any machine or
computer
built to survive that temperature
extreme is going to look [ __ ] up
it's going to look like a tank yeah
tanks can take
probably 250 degrees of temperature yeah
they're built for that
that way if one tank blows up or is
catching on fire
it doesn't [ __ ] destroy the tanks
parked next to it
you know it means i could survive
something like an air an air raid or
yeah make sense you know
that way they can resist damage you know
they can be in a hangar that catches on
fire and a lot of your tanks survive
you know mango badger says [ __ ] me and
tom are almost the same age yeah
so you remember what it was like then
seeing all that [ __ ] for the first time
and you know it was new to the world so
you'll never really see that again not
in our
not not in our era i mean i think when
you watch
new movies because i mean i have to do
this to look i'm almost 48 and it's like
i
try to especially with horror movies
because you know i'm a big horror junkie
and i love horror movies
so i always try to put myself in the
mindset of
i don't i don't want to get to a point
where i'm just like so cynical that
i can't like get into a movie or i can't
um
you know just kind of lose myself in the
world of the movie so i do actually
always try to do that
um you know it doesn't always work
obviously because
sometimes the movies aren't that great
or aren't that engaging but i
usually will like give it a chance yeah
and try to finish it and try to get
engaged within trying to get involved
with it just because i mean somebody
made that and like somebody spent like
all this time and always had all these
people i got together and made it and i
respect that
so you know just because it's not always
successful
i'm not going to like [ __ ] all over the
city and another thing is is that just
because something's made by a [ __ ]
badass
director that has has a a lot of good
movies behind that doesn't mean the
movie's going to be good either
well i try to take everything as as a
singular
like it seems to be to me that um
directors have a half-life like cameron
his word ain't [ __ ] to me i mean he's
come out with a lot of bad movies lately
well it's just kind of like musicians
not always but it's like most of the
their best stuff is when they when
they're younger
um you know once they start getting
older and more complacent you have a
[ __ ] ton of money and it's like they
don't really need they're not hungry
anymore
they're in paid commercials and [ __ ]
inside the [ __ ] movie and [ __ ]
with their
they're [ __ ] with their own um uh
cannon and everything in their own films
like uh for instance a predator the
predator franchise was doing good you
didn't have to change anything about
predators taking people's dna and
that didn't need any of those that
complication
that actually that actually [ __ ] up
the lore
they should have just left it alone the
best thing the best thing about the
predator is not to talk too much about
it
because the more you [ __ ] talk about
that alien and the same thing those
goddamn xenomorphs don't talk about them
because the more you know about them the
the more demystified
more demystified they were i say that
about every single
you've now foreign it away and
also the more you explain something the
more like the
the larger the likelihood that you're
going to like contradict some [ __ ] yeah
there's all kinds of
gonna get mad at you yeah it starts to
contradict
i mean you can't leave things so
nebulous that
you know you can't get a hold of it that
it's too slippery or whatever but
you can't especially in horror suspense
or something like that you can't
over explain your monster your villain
or anything it just takes all of the
you know it takes all the mystique away
it takes all the fun away
um you know you just yeah you just can't
do it
and they [ __ ] up terminator by uh
showing you
skynet as soon as skynet takes on some
kind of human form
and starts speaking and now you can
communicate with skynet
there goes all your mystique yeah
because now it's like a known quantity
it's an entity that you can communicate
back and forth with is much scarier
when it was just some kind of like thing
and you didn't know didn't know what it
was
what it was or how it operated or it was
just some kind of an insect
type computer intelligence somewhere in
a computer that's all you need to know
yeah and honestly you know coming back
to this particular
movie um lake of death i think that was
actually even though like i said this
was a this was a fine movie it was
you know fair to middling um you know
not great not
terrible um if you like this type of
thing you like norwegian horror you like
kind of like old school like
supernatural kind of stuff
i did like that they left it
kind of ambiguous i guess they didn't
leave it super ambiguous but they did
leave it ambiguous as to
uh i don't want to spoil it but what the
nature of
the haunting was i guess i don't know if
haunting is the word that i would use
um but i'm trying to keep it kind of
vague but so they did kind of
leave it as to how much of the [ __ ] was
supernatural how much of it was
imagination hatch which i usually like
that's usually a good thing to do is
leaving things ambiguous i know it does
piss some people off but
i think that's a better i don't know i
just think in horror that makes a better
like makes more of an impact and it
makes you remember because it it
you know it spurs discussion i think why
they keep calling you see there's
another one that's a different number
though i don't know why they keep
calling me from over there
stop calling her
stop calling me yeah i'm not gonna
answer it i don't even answer the phone
when it's somebody i know we've got to
end this stream
i gotta get in there and make some [ __ ]
well we have to uh record too
like after because remember i told you
but we have to do that as well and we
got to make shirts
and we got to make shirts today i
thought we were going to do it yesterday
but we never got around to it okay all
right so we are going to
uh finish up this live stream today
talking about
lake of death which is now streaming on
shutter if you want to check it out yes
okay movie
it's uh yeah it's like i said it's
completely decent if you just want a
creepy movie to watch and you don't
really
want to get all that invested in it it's
it's fine
we'll probably do another live stream
tomorrow either another matinee or
another
uh or a sidetracks or whatever we'll
think of something so uh we'll see you
guys again
tomorrow afternoon bye
okay yeah